all right just got out of the movie
Victor Frankenstein but talking about
that chicken way because we have
ourselves our first trailer for Captain
America Civil War and this is one I have
been looking forward to ever since it
was announced I was like yeah that's the
stuff I'm gonna dress this right off the
bat the scope of this version of Civil
War is not as big as the comic book at
least not from this trailer so far what
we've seen is Tony Stark and Rhodey
fighting a few Avengers obviously the
teams do grow because we get a glimpse
of Black Panther kicking Winter Soldier
which is pretty cool I love the fact
that they showed us Black Panther still
no spider-man no not that I want to see
spider-man yeah II keep that one in the
dark I like to be surprised
not to mention Black Widow we didn't see
her lined up and fighting anything but
she is on the phone with Steve Rogers
she's like please don't fight this
you're gonna make it worse so we don't
see who she's fighting for but you do
get the feeling she's like I work for
the government I'm going to have to
fight you
so we'll say she's probably on Iron
Man's side which is also interesting
because Hawkeye is on Captain America's
side and those two are tight so that
sucks for them but truth be told from
this trailer seeing the scope of this
version of Civil War like where would
spider-man even fit in this looks to be
a very personal story about Captain
America it is a proper Captain America
sequel which I have zero problem with
whatsoever a very personal story about
Steve Rogers and his friend Bucky Barnes
made for one of the best movies in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe top 2 for sure
so if this keeps with that tradition
awesome I'm completely in money I saw
William Hurt in here and I was like
William Hurt I feel like he was in a
Marvel movie before so oh my gosh he was
Colonel [ __ ] in the Incredible Hulk
obviously that dude got a promotion but
the bummer is we have heard reports that
the incredible Hulk's not going to be in
Civil War I guess he was going to be and
then he was scrapped if you like the
movie is now missing out on something
that could be very volatile having the
Incredible Hulk in this movie along with
Colonel dick from The Incredible Hulk
however I'm sure Colonel dick in this
movie does have his agenda because as
you learn the Incredible Hulk project
was more or less springboarding off of
the super serum that made Captain
America so I'm sure he's like yeah I've
seen what that serum does yeah Iron Man
take him out however you were one of the
people one of the two people on the face
of the planet who did not see the
post-credits scene in ant-man don't
worry you don't have to it's in this
trailer I never seen them do that before
just show a post-credits scene in a
trailer it's like like it's not secret
anymore
there's nothing sacred and that scene
where Captain America's like
sorry Tony you know I wouldn't do this
if there was any other way but he's my
friend I love Tony Stark's response to
that because it's actually quite sad
he's like so was I and that's the first
time I've really gathered that I mean I
knew they were teammates and whatnot and
they're definitely different ideologies
between the two right there it's like
Tony Stark's like I really felt like we
were friends Tony Stark lost a friend
today possibly - I don't think roadies
gonna die I feel like when Robert Downey
jr. is done with these movies Tony Stark
is going to die and then roadies going
to become the new Iron Man building
Rhodey would just eliminate that
possibility inside I don't think they're
going to do that and you gotta love that
last shot that team-up with Captain
America and Winter Soldier just beating
the living piss out of Iron Man never
underestimate the power of the duel tech
that's all I'm saying that is what we
wanted to see in the trailer - Captain
America Civil War and that is what we
got to see - in the end yeah Captain
America Civil War the trailer was great
it shows us what we're in for
it shows a line has been drawn between
Steve Rogers and Tony Stark and the
people who will ally themselves with
them not as large-scale as the comic
book we knew it wouldn't be but this is
more personal scale than even I thought
it was going to be but Captain America
having the best of the personal stories
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe totally
cool with that and something tells me
it's going to be bigger than this
trailer showing us or just saving it for
later because like yeah we don't want to
show you everything idiot so the Captain
America civil war trailer have you seen
it what did you think about it and whose
side are you on Iron Man or Captain
America whatever you think whatever side
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more